hey guys Pete here today I'm going to
tackle one of the mysteries from the
first three parts of 22 returned and I'm
talking about the mysterious glass box I
actually started out thinking about more
than just the box in New York City but
realize that there's plenty enough for a
whole video here so next week I will get
into episode threes beginning sequence
and the character dougie I would have
liked to limit the scope of the spoilers
here to just the first two parts but
some of what we saw on part three is
likely important here so if you haven't
watched episode three yet come back to
this video after you have otherwise it
will be spoiled the glass box was
introduced early and located somewhere
in New York City as the name suggests
it's literally a giant glass box and it
has a porthole to the outside it's
surrounded by cameras that are
constantly monitoring it and it's
sitting on top of a lot of electrical
equipment I'm no expert in that so I
don't know exactly what all that stuff
is but it definitely looks high-tech we
know there are people who are hired to
watch the cameras watching the glass box
and what little info we get about it
comes from one of the hired hands whose
name is Sam Sam is a college student who
watches the box to make some extra money
he has no idea what the box is for but
it tells us it was set up by an
anonymous billionaire who he's never met
Sam's friend Tracy stops lied to bring
him coffee and we learned that the
laboratory for lack of a better term has
24-hour security and that no one besides
the hired help are allowed in however
the next time Tracy stops by Sam goes
out to see what's going on because he
doesn't get you know the alert from the
security guard and they both realize
that there is no security guard there
this allows Tracy to get inside and
potentially set an event into motion
Tracy makes a move on Sam and the couple
proceeds to get down as they're making
out on the couch Sam notices something
is happening with the box at this point
we see a white figure that has human
features materializing inside the box
this thing is never totally visible you
know it's pretty blurry but it's plain
to see that it's
not very happy it continues to get more
agitated before it ultimately bakes
through the glass and flashes Sam and
Tracy to death in a nutshell that's the
info we have now I've read some pretty
interesting ideas and theories both in
the comments here and in some different
articles and I was looking at read it as
well and some of the things that I've
read about the glass box align with my
own thoughts and guesses and some are a
little bit further out for me my first
question about the mysterious box was
and still is was it set up at a point
similar to what you know we know
Glastonbury grows to be like a portal or
does it somehow function to draw energy
or in this case an entity in its
direction I think the previous is more
likely but there are clear problems with
both explanations which is what makes it
so interesting and fun to think about if
it's a portal like the ring of Sycamore
trees why is it upstairs in a building
rather than somewhere on the ground on
the other hand if it's a catcher of
sorts like the electronic equipment it
pulls otherworldly stuff in its
direction who on earth would have enough
information to put something like this
together either way we have seen two
different events inside the box it looks
look closer at those what I haven't
talked about yet is that agent Cooper
made a stop here on his transition from
the Red Room hallway back into the real
world this is presented in a nonlinear
fashion because Sam is out in the
hallway looking for the security guard
at the exact same moment Cooper enters
the box he passes unnoticed and only the
camera footage exists that's a clue that
he was there in the timeline the white
figure shows up just after Cooper when
Tracy and Sam returned to the room so
are these two things connected like did
the figure follow Cooper or is it just
completely unrelated now in order to
Cole I read on movie pilot calm was it
was written by Alexander Eckstein Khan
she points out two viable but pretty
different possibilities right so the
first would be the figure is a
manifestation of the arms doppelganger
and you know there are some definite
similarities especially
now you know just the way the two things
look could the DA palarm have sent agent
Cooper out which we know that it did and
then followed right behind him the
second option is that these two things
have nothing at all to do with each
other they just happen to have you know
occur right after one another so they're
the white figure was attracted by what
was going on in the room why would we
think that Sam and Tracy attracted the
you know the figure well if you remember
back the season two major Briggs tells
Windom Earle that fear and love opened
the doors to the black and white lodges
I know this is terribly open-ended and
vague but we know that Sam never saw
anything while watching the Box by
himself this could be a clue or a red
herring that they're making out and the
fear that was involved with that may
have played a part there was obviously
strong feelings going on whether they
were lust or love is up to you but there
should have been a real fear of being
caught we could go completely in major
Briggs this direction here because I
think he is important especially based
on the secret history stuff but I will
explore that more in the video about the
opening sequence of part three that I'll
put out next week for me the next
logical question is who set this room up
the possibilities are endless
like literally but here are the things
that I've read from least to most likely
in my opinion number one it's Audrey
Horne we haven't seen her yet and no
she's coming back but that's pretty much
the total of all of the evidence related
to this theory so I think it's pretty
unlikely number two it's mr. Todd in Las
Vegas this is possible but again the
basis for this idea is that we really
don't know who he is yet and that we
think he is probably influenced by Bob
through evil koop personally I think mr.
Todd is related to the dougie situation
but we really don't know enough yet so
it could be mr. Todd but still not very
likely
number three evil coupe set up the Box
himself now this is somewhat likely I
would say coupe would have more info
than most people about the lodges and
the portals related to them so it might
just be
that set that thing up we don't know
what his resources and things are but
he's obviously not hurting based on that
Mercedes that he drives around and what
you know whatever we just really don't
know that much but he could probably
string it together number four and this
is who I thought it was when I first
thought about this I think it probably
the most likely candidate anyways is the
person who able to talk to through that
electronic device in his briefcase this
could be someone impersonating Phillip
Jeffries David Bowie's character from
fire walk with me or it could actually
be Jeffries we may never see this
character so it may not we may not need
David Bowie for that to be a
confirmation that it's Jeffries what we
know is that this person is connected
with the large stuff as he says that you
know he will be with Bob again when evil
coupe goes back in and we know if he's
not referees he at least knows who he is
he also mentions major Briggs in the
mystery around him pretty much points to
him having some sort of power over evil
coupe if not anything else but
information he seems to have access to
information and things that coupe
doesn't have himself so I think that's
what's most likely now I want to hear
what you guys think like I said I will
be following up with this and we'll talk
more about major Briggs in the secret
history next week but for right now what
do you guys think sup with this box do
you think we're going to learn more
about this stuff or do you think it's
just something that's supposed to be a
mystery I think it's pretty clear that
it is connected to the box that we see
in outer space and that's why I'm making
that into a second video but what do you
think about that do you think that's
what that is it's just that whoever set
it up they set it up as a catcher to
sidetrack things from going where
they're supposed to go or do you think
that it's just there because that's a
very sensitive place and who do you
think the mysterious billionaire or you
know that's it doesn't even have to be a
billionaire really someone that has a
lot of money who do you think that is
also the security guards they
disappeared and another thing to think
about related to that is because they
disappear the FBI now it has
access to all that information remember
Tammy was briefing Cole and Albert and I
took that to be that they have in
custody all of the the digital tapes so
that would mean that they're going to
realize that Cooper passed through there
so yeah I don't know tell me what you
think about this mysterious box and
let's go from there thanks for watching
out talk to you soon